realitätsverlust lügen und ein riesiger
schuldenberg schlagerstar michael
wendler ist mit seinem vater manfred
seit jahren zerstritten in seinem ersten
buch die wahrheit über meinen sohn
michael wendler macht sich der vater
luft seine verschwörungstheorien finde
ich abscheulich es gibt viele menschen
die an corona sterben nach wie vor immer
mehr werden sich infizieren und er ist
so was los so was überhaupt nicht ich
weiß nicht was ihn jemand erfahren haben
so haben sozusagen er gut leben und geld
zu verdienen selbst geld zu verdienen
doch das haut nicht hin da hatte er
meine tochter wird je nach aus auge
gedrückt mit sehr viel schon gelacht
heute circa 400.000 euro schulden ab und
er kümmert sich überhaupt nicht darum
überhaupt nicht das kennt man von ihm
alle die bei gegen
schlange stehen um die gelder zu
bekommen gehen alle leer aus so ist
michael er hat so viel schulden jeden
deutschland hinterlassen sehr viele
schulen ich kenne sehr viele gläubiger
dass er nie wieder glaube ich zumindest
nie wieder nach deutschland zurückkehren
ich denke wenn seine partnerin laura
deutschland sind käme würde würde ich
auch sagen die würde keine plattform
mehr bei rtl oder so
die medien anfangs mehr aber auch nicht
was da abgelaufen ist und hör auf meine
worte
der tag wird kommen da wird hier in
deutschland einreisen aber der wird dann
jedoch kommt mit seiner claudia wieder
zusammenarbeiten
das ist meine vermutung und so wird es
auch sein so dass ich das gemacht was
diese woche auf dem markt und ich hoffe
dass alle menschen gehen in deutschland
dieses buch lesen und über den inhalt
bescheid ich so viel mein sohn überhaupt
am ganzen jahren gegangen ließ nicht nur
mit mir sondern die gesamten familie
da sah ich meine tochter selbst seine
mutter oder von ihm dermaßen reingelegt
und das schon alles hier weiß gewesen in
meinem buch
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren